As transition, let me get back to that segue.
You have all of this work which you are clearly proud of.
And you've still written a song from your second album.
I'm sure everyone requests songs from your first album...
...as well as from your new album. Well now...
...looking back, has it been a big transition?
Have you changed a lot over the last eight years since your debut?
I'm happy and very proud to say, I just had the ten-year anniversary.
My first album, it's been eight years since my last solo album, however.
And there've been many, many, many changes.
Probably the biggest is especially so many people love my debut album.
And that's still very much requested and cherished by my fans who've been around...
...and followed me for the last decade.
But some of those songs that I wrote on that album; I was 14, 15 years old when I wrote them.
Isn't that crazy? Like Justin Bieber.
Well, I listened to the record,...
"...What was I writing?"
"Where did I get this inspiration? I was like, at school!"
"How did this happen?" I had a very overactive imagination.
And I would listen to songs and watch films, and read books...
...and kind of create these fictional situations to write about and draw from.
The difference being now ten years later, I traveled the world.
I've had good relationships.
I've lived through good,...
...I've lived through bad.
I've grown up a lot.
So, the writing is a lot more personal.
And so that's probably the biggest change is lyrically, I think...
...I have more personal connection now to the songs...
...that I write and I did that.